Good morning Max ang greetings to our new cookies.
This isn't home, this is not home.
It is now.
It's very different here.
My monkey, she does for poop a day. What?
First my friends become not my friends
Then giving a color that other colors want to fight
Use and khakis have beef with each other pink sir safe out there
Female friendships is so complicated
Where is Alex don't you think it's weird were the only people in here they want us to all know
regardless of what we did or didn't do
You're gonna give up the rest of your life to protect some lousy criminal my man is enemies these days
sometimes I wonder whose team you really
What does it really stand? Why are you lying to me? She had to already be coming for me, but I'm gonna keep standing up
We have iron wells and fucking nothing to lose
Roll it out and wrist roll roll it out. Churn the butter churn the butter
You